Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Sort The Court.
Now the last time I played this game was almost
TWO
*breath*
YEARS
AGO
To the day
and since then it's received one more major
update. So I'm gonna play and in addition to that you get to play as a king or queen
and I don't think that was in the game before but now, I'm gonna be a queen.
I'M BEAUTIFUL!!! (Yes you are :>)
Hello. "My lady. I'll help you rule your kingdom."
Ehh.... no.
I don't get it. "Very funny. Just give people their answers okay?"
"Our city is still very small right now, but it certainly has a potential to grow."
"Perhaps one day we will have a bustling metropolis and you'll be invited to join the Council of Crowns!"
I don't remember there being a Council of Crowns before.
"For now all you need to concern yourself with is keeping the citizens happy and growing our population. Do your best madam!"
I shall ... I shall venture to do my best
Hello!
"Want me to steal from the rich and give to-"
"You? not just the rich I'll steal from whoever basically"
THAT'S MORALLY AMBIGUOUS!!!
I'm not morally amb-  excuse me. I'm trying to get my foot in a comfortable position here. That's not mor-
I am NOT a morally ambiguous
Individual go to HELL
"Taking the high road, huh? I'll see you around." Alright, whatever. I actually was trying to move my foot in a comfortable way
Everybody just bear with me. I don't know how long the video is gonna be when I'm done
But I'm taking the long road for this one. Oh, hi "It's just staring at me. Does it want something?"
Yeah, it does. It sure does
Oh "What just happened? I feel lucky." Oh good! It's my lucky day. Thank you.
Thank you eye, goodbye.
*vampire BLEH* "I am the Duke of spook. Do you want a spooky nickname?"
Of course, I do little Fang "Hmm... you can be...The Creep Queen?" I'll take it. Alright, I'm the creep queen. Hi
Hello butt demon. "Hey bud care to flip a coin with me? Heads: I'll give you a buncha gold."
"Tails: I take a bunch of your people's souls."
Well, I mean, I feel pretty lucky. So why not?
uh oh ... "Ohoho, it's tails. I'll be taking those souls better luck next time." Well, that's inconvenient
Well, at least I have money people are sad the city is shrinking
What? the people are one-off from sadness?
But people are the baseline is a hundred
B0k B0k! "It's running wild. Should we try to capture it?" Yeah
We should,
Oh
Whoa, this thing is dangerous. It just killed somebody
How did that chicken kill Grandma?
"Eeeeeh. I was considering opening up a soup shop." Yes, of course Grandma
There's literally no way that I would not do that for Grandma and somehow Grandma brought our whole family of ten people involved
"I'll sell my soup in the town square"
Thanks. Grandma."My lady. I wish to embark on a treacherous quest!" You go you go man
You do your thing "For the kingdom! I shall return to you lady!"
Alright, thank you. Take care with you. Whatever wooh Hi.
"Name's Molder. If you want anything to know the truth about everything... You're gonna want to hire me? Okay
"I'm gonna go... investigate something." Ah thanks Molder. Oh, hey, how's it going? One of our prisoners escaped!
May I have some gold offer a reward for her recapture? Yeah. Okay Oh
Someone's bound to find her soon with this sweet reward
I'm kind of running out of gold here
Place were a little better off
People are sad. Does it go up to 200? What about your baloney? What a bunch of malarkey? Ook. He's got a shiny coin
Okay. Ook ook ook. OO0O0O0O0O0K!!
Always to instruct a tavern. I'm trying to get in New York accent going on for this guy
Hey, I wish to construct a tavern, but I'll need some gold from you to make it happen
That's terrible guys the worst let me try again
AY!
Why do I gotta start with that? AY! I wish to instruct a tavern here!
AY! I'm constructor
Tavernier hey, I'm constructing a tavern here
Fuck I wish to construct a tavern, but I'll need some gold from you to make it happen
I'm talking considerable. Not a gold couple under at least. What do you think?
I only have 195 but if that's okay, I'll do it. Well shit the town's folk will be happy to have a place to drink
All right. Well, I'm dirt poor. So that's not good. The Treasury is empty m'lady
We could raise taxes a bit further, but the people won't like it much should we try?
No, it's okay. We'll make up the gold somehow. We still need to resolve the issue of having no money
We'll get to it eventually but not at the cost of happiness
You seems like you need some gold in exchange for a few souls. Maybe how about it? No suppose
You'll have to look elsewhere for the coin then
yeah, that would just make him unhappy and that's what I just didn't do for the tower oway
Need of cash. I could hook you up if you let me eat a few folks
How about it No, thank you Chester. I used to find some other way out of this myth, huh?
Yes, I will Chester people are happy. The city is growing. Well, that's good. We get some tax money
No, Chester stop. No, no bad chests bad treasure is empty. We could raise taxes. I
Guess better than letting them eat people. Oh
We still lose. Yeah. All right. Well, we got money from taxes. So I guess that's good
AY! working conditions are unsafe. Will you please spend some gold on improving our ability to work?
I am
I'm the worst. Yeah. Okay safety is my number-one concoin
Thank you
the builders appreciate this
Frick I feel awful and the Duke of spook. Do you want a spooky nickname?
Yeah, sure
You can be the creep queen. The bow is already the creep queen
I'm ready to make my report seems the merchants guild is being controlled by alien conspirators. How do I know this?
Sometimes you just know you know, yeah, I know I get you. Yeah, I know, you know, you're a knower, thanks
Thanks for noticing. My knowing people are sad the city's shrinking.
I was just passing through and thought you might like some magic I never say no to magic
Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Goddammit our city is dying because of my negligent ability to rule
Oh, look a coin flipper. Let's throw this bitch. AGHHHHHH!! **Markimoo intensifies** ah shit
Alright, well you seem to be a giant piece of shit. Hello
Any mystery afoot? I can do some snoopin for a small fee
Okay, you go you snoop you snoop it up. You get the truth, whatever it may be. However, it may help me. Hi
Oh god, you haven't been talking to Skelly, have you?
Uhhhhhhhhhh... No
If you say so I sure have an alien
Hey bud care to flip a coin? Alright this time you better you better get it to me
AHHH! There we go, thank you. Thank you Georg-ie. My people are pissed off
There's a party going on in the tavern the citizens rejoice singing and dancing together into the night. I am a bad
Ruler, I'm a bad queen. We lost a quarter of our populate
We lost a third we lost a third of our population in one day god damn it
You ever seen your treasure chest do a back flip? No. I honestly never have where you're not gonna
Okay
Thank you. Grandma! Hello, sweetie. Can I borrow a coin for the newspaper?
Of course, you can grandma any time Thank you, Dearie! A petition to bring the circus to town is circulating could attract tourists
Are you interested? Yeah around the clown's. There we go. Let's have the circus in without was nothing but good
That was those nothing but good there was nothing but Chi yes
Okay, thank you now, I've got money but my people are still gonna leave me oh
whoa HO HO
MIGHT I JUGGLE YOUR BALLS? OHOHOHO
Yeah, okay
Ha ha very good
All right. Thank you French juggler
The circus is in town bringing joy to all who visit it also happens to bring a nice bit of golden cool
My people are still leaving but this next day is gonna be a new day. There's a bunch of goblins in the lower corner
I'll slay him for a few gold. If you want ok, go for it. Have fun. Also enough cramps. My lady I have returned
I'm ashamed to inform you that I returned with nothing shall I show myself to the dungeons Oh
No, you're fine
You forgive me Oh kind and gracious Lord bless you. I didn't sneeze. But thank you
I'm such a good Queen. There's a very stinky kid running around the streets. Should we force her to have a bath?
Yes, hygiene is of the utmost importance
Glad you agree. She won't be happy though. Well sucks to suck
You gotta be clean him might I'd get us a cup of tea for you milady
Ok, sure
Yes, nice and hot madam
Alright you freakin weirdo. Why you gotta be weird like that? Hello?
It seems happy. Okay, good. That's good. Serkis is still going and wheeze are happy Oh
Wheeze are happy Oh wheezes. So a happy or wheezing the happiest
Oh look at us and how happy weaves is grandma
I read quite the troubling tale in the paper today. You think everything will be alright grandma?
Are you kidding me?
Everything said to be just fine grandma. You have nothing to worry about. I hope you're right
I am right grandma a visit anytime grandma. I've collected some incomes from the circus. Would you like me to tax them? Yes
Very well, the proceeds will be added to the Treasury. That's how income works right? Huh? Whoa
Take the girl, I mean the gold take the gold don't take my people
fuck
Oh, yes, I'll take that
Good god, man
Jeez, good day madam. Do you require any haunting services for a small price? I'll scare some people for you. Ah
No, thank you
Very well very well. I mean I didn't need it miss your spirit
I would like some money please sure cuz we're just handing tonight. Oh my god. Thank you for the money. Good madam
This is good money
Why did I give you money? Who the hell are you yet who?
This is a bit of a kerfuffle
We're in a bit of trouble. I've got a business proposition for you in your tiny little town. Are you interested?
Well, you're a little insulting you dick. But okay, I will bring you details soon. All right, you're teasing piece of garbage
Oh hi
Hey pal, you've been a real great sport. So I wanted to give you this no strings attached. Really? Oh, thanks. Thank you
That's so nice
The people have started a petition to ban pineapples in the city. Should we do it? No, I love
pineapples
Sticking up for pineapples. How admirable
Who doesn't love pineapples now pineapples on pizza? That's a de Bhama nation, but an
Escaped prisoner has been recaptured. Thanks to the bounty you offered our citizens can rest. No easier
Okay, I accidentally ate some folks out front. Can I pay you back with gold?
Yes, oh
Thanks for understanding nope, nope, nope, nope, no problem
Care to gaze into my magical vampire crystal art if you whip your dick out
Again, I'm going to be incredibly pissed but I will look oh
Come on our city. Can't take this you see death and mr. Screw you
Screw you and your magic balls my boats too. Tiny to catch many fish. Can I have some gold to upgrade that stop payback?
I swear. All right, go for it. We've got gold and no people. Oh
You won't regret this you'll see
Thank you. Nice beard. Hello, sweetie. Can I borrow coin? Of course grandma always grandma?
You got a skeleton of your own, you know, don't you find it weird that you can't see it? No, not that weird
No, you don't think anything's weird. Do ya. No, not not really. I mean the dragon that walked its way in here
Hey, could I trouble you for a sandwich?
surely the cost of one sandwich is nothing - to a great queen like you oh
My god, I'm sorry. I am sorry. Yeah, okay take a sandwich
Fantastic. Hey, I'm excited to eat this. It's like some horrible Christopher Walken hybrid oof
We're doing poorly
We're doing poorly. Oh, hi. Mom says, I need to ask your permission to go on an adventure. So can I please please?
Yes, go for it. Yeah, I'm excited
Alright, why do you need my permission?
Citizen say a monkey has been running around flinging stuff at them. Should we put a bounty on it? Yeah go for that
We'll have that monkey captured in no time. Oh, hi buddy. I'm ba ba bum ba dum bum Boosh you like my rhythm bra
I am a lady, but that's okay. I'll overlook it. Nice rhythm. Yeah
I'm in the groove
Alright, okay. Thank you. We've captured some foes on the battlefield. Shall we bring them home and put them to work?
Well, that sounds like slavery
so
No, I understand however we need to do something with them till we ransom the captured foes off for a bit of gold. Yes
Very well better to have golden hostile captives. Thank you. I think why did you need to yell at me?
Oh, hi, big guy home the blacksmith and I'd like to set up shop here. I can pay my own way
I just need your permission
What do you say?
Okay
Yeah, I'll show you my incredible skill just you wait
Thank you. Thank you. There's a party going on the tavern hell
Yeah, okay citizens are upset about whether or not ransoming. Our prisoners was the right choice
There's been some unrest about the decision. Well, too freaking bad
What were we gonna do?
Keep up here. There would have been pissed and killed people
Whatever police were growing
Madam, I heard about the dragon attack. You were made to endure. I've come up with an idea to strike back
I can craft a blade powerful enough to slay the dragon and Draco those treasures won't be easy though
I need to track down the finest metals, but they're quite costly might I have a few hundred gold to begin my search
Okay, go for it. Thank you. Madam. I'll keep you posted about further developments. I won't let you down
I'll strike back at that dragon yet
Okay, you better cuz we're poor both people poor happy poor and gold poor
I saw a beautiful silver gauntlet in the blacksmith today. May I have the funds to purchase it? Okay. Yeah. Sure
You're the knight, I guess. Thank you lady. I shall use it in defense of our proud Kingdom
Okay, thank you a caravan of mine wishes to camp in your city for the next few days might that be arranged
Okay quite agreeable. We shall work together again. I hope you still need to tell me about that the thing oh
you
All right, buddy, all right Gandalf we're gonna trust you again I never say no to magic I
Should have said no to magic. Why isn't there dare for magic god damn it. I'm back
I found these shiny yellow stones pretty cool, right? Yeah pretty cool
So cool
Well, thank you. Guess that helps a little bit citizens been trading within that good
People are sad. The city is shrinking. I'm sad. I've got a business proposition
Yeah, I am. Okay cool is the caravan the business proposition? Okay, whatever
Reporting in I discovered an underground crime ring in the city's eastern ward. I've already taken steps to break up their operations
Can I have a bit of extra gold to bring in the guards and make some additional arrests? Yeah, go for it
It seems like a good use perfect. We'll have those criminals locked up in by this time another man tomorrow you
okay, I never
say no to
magic, I
never say no to
Magic, if you screw me over again delft, there will be no limit to my rage
What kind of bad luck hi grandma, I'm sorry
Grandma, it's fine. Everything's gonna be fine. Grandma. Grandma. Everything is going to be just fine. Don't worry. Don't worry
Grandma, the guild of pineapple traders offers you a gift madam. Will you accept it? Yes, if please be pint of oh
That's good enough
Okay
People are sad they're gonna leave
Great. Yeah, looks like he wants something Patty's belly. Okay? Yes, please. Thank you. Morale boots, okay
He's so enthralled by you and your abs that's what I thought
Oh
I'm so into it. Yeah, you're you are please just
Go away. Oh sure. My name is madam a bear a bear a bear
My name is madam agua, and I've come to join your court. Will you have me? Yep, how sweet?
I'm sure many wonderful adventures await us
I'm sorry who cook he's got a shiny coin? Yes, he does
Yes, he does not again Dan Delfy I swear to God
I swear I swear I'm gonna close my eyes. I'm gonna look at yes. Okay, I'm gonna close my eyes
I'm gonna press yes and you are gonna give me something good
Hey
That was not worth it two hundred two hundred
Thousand god damn you dirty day fourteen worse
Hi you find me humorous
That's that's so fun, it's a good it's a good one cheer me right up cheer this whole town up
We're gonna grow now Oh God
Hey, it's slime day
got a
present for me
Yeah
Okay. You're so nice
I sure AM slime man. Hello. Your beautiful plants are interesting. Don't you think I would like to open a garden?
May I have some workers to help me? Yeah
My town my tiny town hey, I'd like to build a granary
this could help expand our
Population but it'll cost a bit. Okay
You got it
This will help our city grow
My lady, I wish to embark on a treacherous quest
Go for it for the kingdom. I shall return to you lady. Alright, thank you. Oh look, the people are happy
The extra food we've been able to store in the granaries is attracting more settlers. Shall we let them in? Yeah
Okay, very good. We'll have them settled it in once okay, we're climbing back out of the brink
We were at the bottom don't you don't know no. No, I can't say no to magic. I can't say no, I
Never say no
Thank you dad, ow, you're really fueling my gambling addiction and never say no how hundun no
No
No, go away. Go go. Get out of here. Stop
You just can't seem slightly magical. Not sure what it wants though
I never say no to magic. So okay, I guess that's good. Hello, buddy. It seems sad. Oh
That's helpful. The people are happy the city's growing
My lady, there's a man in the for yay asking to join your God
He's got an eyepatch looks little shifty. What do you think? Should we take a chance on this stranger? Listen I've taken chances on
wizards
magical chests flying but demons, eyeballs
Why would I be bothered by a normal stranger indeed most walls would help us? Hello?
the guards confiscated some gold that I
Found no
No, no. No, you're keeping it. But I stopped. I mean I found it, how'd it go?
Accidentally stand about not eating candies. Can I have some girl to get to the dark door?
Yes, I never thought I could eat too many sweets Oh
Aren't you just delightful? Hello?
Did you exist before I don't think I can fix you, but I'll try
Thanks friend I am become
Fixed. Alright you and become go to the English teacher because you is not good at that. I love madam
Are you looking for experience barbers in your court?
If you're implying that you're an experienced barber and you walk in here looking like you stuck your head in a blender
I'm gonna say yes, they're not shall join you
I'm the best of the best but cursed with not being able to cut my own hair
Only the hair of others. Well, at least we're growing. Hey, we're making progress
We're finally climbing back Oh God want me to do a drumroll?
Alright, here we go
Yes, I
Knew you'd like it. All right. Thanks, buddy. Ah
Why?
Must you darken my doorway
wizard
I've been playing for maybe twenty days. You've been here for six of them. Yes Oh
My Luck has turned around my gambling addiction is being fueled
Probably not a good thing but here we are
There's been a brawl at the tavern should we arrest those responsible for starting it?
People fight it's fine. Just nice. It's all good. It's fine. No
But they're sure to cause more trouble if oh
wait
No, wait. Wait, no wait, come back
Arrest them. I change my mind. It is nice to see you madam. Do you like my new haircut? Ah
Instead of a blender you decided to stick to frisky beavers in your hair and let them
Go to town inside of you. Ah
Yeah, okay
My lady I have returned. I'm ashamed again. It's fine
But why do you keep going on these quests if you're not getting anything? No, you forgive me. Yes, I forgive you
Why I didn't even throw people that fought in the tavern into the dungeons. Why would I throw you?
We're almost at where we started. Yayyy
You feeling spooky today. Yes, I am
Heck oh
Wait, no. Wait, no. Wait. No, that's no no man you hide earlier. I was gone missing shall we send a search party?
Yes, uh
Let's find him at all costs, okay
Yes, I'm making the wrong choices yeah. Hello, sweetie yes grandma
Yes, you can your visits always brightened on my day. Thank you, Grandma. You're so sweet. I love you
Would you like to purchase any swords for your guards? Oh, well protect the city as a happy City. Yep
Sure would thank you great of a shipment a swords sent to your barracks
That was actually pretty cheap happiness there. So I'm down for that for some reason when I look at that camel
It looks like it's balls
Arresting in the middle of its chest. I don't know why. Yeah, we're growing 120. Hey, we're finally making progress
Okay, I'm not gonna make the same mistake twice you arrest those bastards you string them up
You send them to the dungeon you stick him in the iron maiden. You tickle their Tootsie's?
Yes
Okay, I was forgiving before but not now
Want me to steal from- the- No did no no
No, no
Yes, no
Yes, listen, no. Yes, no, no
No
Citizens from far and wide come to visit my barbershop. Would you like a fresh new cut madam free of charge?
Okay. Sure
Of course you do you look dashing. I don't look any different. I'm literally no different. There's nothing. That's hello
Squee there's a mouth should we chase it away?
Petite Souris
No, it's just reading what's wrong with that
It seems happy, okay
Thank you madam about the dragonblade. Yeah, it's what I'm calling the sword now
I've purchased some top-quality metals, but I'll need workers to help me and do the crafting. Can you spare a few?
Yes
This will speed things up. I shall return to you with a magnificent blade madam. Thank you blacksmith
All right, we are growing fast now, huh ma, (huh ma?) come on feeling spooky today no
Opposite of spooky not even a tiny spook a little baby bad. No, no blood is gonna flow today
God, damn, you you the handsome bastard
Give it to me. Ohhhhh
That's been pretty good luck so far
I never say no to magic, baby. All right look hey, buddy
Maybe it's time to hang up the sword. You obviously can't do shit. All right, go for it. All right. Goodbye
I'm a little Timmy. Nice to meet you. You like ice queen. Yeah, I do. Uh-huh. Me too
okay, then you little Timmy you're adorable, but also creepy I
Was to put on a show may I have the funds to do so?
Okay. Oh
Very good
Why there's so many French people in my city
People are happy. The city is growing. Yes. Finally. Good God Oh,
Get your butt back alone in there Oh thinking you may be interested in something a little bigger
Hey
What kind of something are you talking about? And how much bigger are you suggesting?
maybe some kind of devilish ritual something along those lines a lot of souls would get you so let's I
Guarantee you can afford it though. Not gonna wipe out your whole city here. Just
lots of folks
But on the other hand, you'll get crazy amount of money. Like I'm talking serious gold beeps here
I gotta do it tonight moon special right now one chance only. What do you say?
um
well
Gold
How much is a heap uh?
Yeah
No, that's a tempting
um
Probably a bad idea, but I mean everyone's probably screaming at me to go. No, but just I'm
I'm kind of tempted by the heaps
Oh
My god, it's piled up to my ears and beyond
Enjoy your riches Bob. Maybe I'll see you around again sometime. Who knows?
Wow
Thank you
care to gaze into my magical vampire crystal
All right, that didn't work before but you said magical and I literally cannot say no to magic Oh
Pile a little more trickle it up on top there
Can I have a coin a gold coin?
Alright listen kid. I can't spare a single dime. Listen. I have got to budget myself
Hey go for it kid buy you some ice cream
Alright cool
I think my my spina bifida is gonna get worse from hunching over from this gold
Some of the villagers mentioned they saw an alien walking around, you know anything about this I do. Yes, I do
I knew it. I need to go find molder
Okay, fine builders wish to construct more houses. They request gold which would be modified. Okay, go for it
Mmm, I've got plenty of gold
our city grows
It grows richer good
Great. We got 32 people today. It's a
Hundred I think I'm a good queen you call this a cat
Yeah, I eat a dick if you can you ghost indeed it is for question oh
Okay
What oh
Okay, there it is demand for mice ever ceases throw the roof now have your permission to raise my prices?
I mean supply and demand go for it, I guess
Oh
People are happier the Baba's Association. Thanks. Yeah
Okay, it's been a brawl at the Travers. I throw them in jail
Arrest them at once. Oh, oh names Mulder. Wait, I already hired. I know you I
I'm aware of you Mulder go to gaze into my magical
Yeah, I die
You sack of shit. Oh you little piece of garbage you
piece poor Barry my show
Seems to have gone over. Well, I wish to expand my
Production funds I shall need fell hundred gold. Oh
Well, I don't know if I have the goal despair but go for it. Oh
This sure will delight and astound ah
My cold it's only up to my ears now any mysteries afoot? Okay. Well, you said you were gonna go talk to Mulder
So you didn't did you bunch of goblins go for it. Slay those goblins. I'll show those creeps man. Your hips are just
Unbelievable villagers are complaining about garbage in the streets. Shall we hire workers to clean it up? Yes villagers noses
Will thank you surely surely. Don't call me Shirley. Grandma the soup shops been doing. Well. I came to offer you some of our earnings
Grandma grandma. No keep that for your scram. I no need no grandma. No
You are so humble. I'm so
Come on crying so sweet grandma goddamnit grandma demand for my services. Alright fine. Go for it, I guess
That's a messy how hire your service is then? Oh, hi, buddy. My boat's all fixed up. Thanks to you
Something's up and you're back for your loan. Thank you. A nearby town is asked as to form an alliance with them
Should we use them to beef up our ranks?
Okay, sure. Whoa
Easy-peasy just more people. All right, I found a way to summon people from another dimension. Oh
Okay, Oh
Magic of questionable origins. Well, I
Never say no to magic. So there's that
Thank you the extra food more setlist. What is this? Just people our
Wow, okay, we're up to
200 goblins go for it. Go for him. This is going great. Now we're on a roll
There's no way that we could lose. Okay. Hello. You ready for the truth aliens have landed in there in our city?
You think we're safe? No, no. No, we're not worrying won't change anything. They're already here among us. Oh
Well, they're adding to the population. So I guess that's good
My sales have brought in record profits and I'd like to give you something. Will you accept my gift? Oh sure. Very good
Very good. Thank
You I do believe I have perfected my shawl
Gold it does require but happiness it shall bring. Oh
700 gold my lord. I can put my show 1 small
Your show hasn't done garbage. Why why am I giving Gold?
Why why am I I've given you like 1500 gold
Why I mean am I still giving you gold? No, no, no. No my gold Oh
The gesture continues to amaze the core with a combination of a skill and his ever increasing special effects budget
Well, I guess that's good happiness is the root of all and happy. I don't know
We're growing fast
and I guess that really was what matters madam the city's population is growing steadily in our records of citizenship indicate that
250 people now call the city home
But the bigger city will need to maintain even higher happiness in order to keep people satisfied
Make sure you pay attention to the citizens and their issues to raise our happiness
Remember earlier when I mentioned the Council of crowns. Yeah
I heard a rumor that one of their members had started searching the land for a new ruler to join them
Perhaps they are aware of our progress. Okay, I'll join I'll do that. Hey, uh
somebody came by and
Cleaned my home
You're gonna pay me back for them. Yeah. Yeah, I guess I guess this soon dude
I mean, I can't really make slime for you. So no we'd like to purchase any swords from my guards
Well protective have a sitter. Yep. We are happy as a clam
Grab, ah, oh
Grandma no, you keep them. Grandma. You keep it grandma. You keep it. I really want them
How are you? It seems your court is without a much cake. I can provide cake. I'm a Kate chef
May I join you?
Yeah, okay Louis. You're you're more than welcome here. Thank you
Bye Kate
Will make you cakes
Can be sure of that. All right Thank You Louis
Scary scary Louis. Okay. All right Louis Louis everybody. Hey, we're growing faster. That's what matters the town
We made an alliance with it's in trouble. Should we send soldiers to a system? Yes, of course. That's what alliances are force
We promised we would protect them. I
Have returned from Mike Wow
Thank You night you're in for a reward later hello
Want some of the patties belly? Okay, I
Mean this is going great. I don't know what the Council of crowns is all about
But I'm gonna find out you think you owe me slimeball. It's hurting my feelings
Yeah, of course
Thanks boss
No one ever calls me boss. Thanks Winston. Um again, I don't know what scaring people would do, but
Okay, I guess ah
Why do you want me to school god damn it you and your trick questions
I just wanted to know what it was like. All right, we're growing that's all that matters
Hey, we're big
Can I have some food? Yeah, of course boots
Yeah, it's the same Mouse from before. Is he offering me something? Yeah. Oh
You found a coin? Oh
What a cutie care to gaze into my magical vampire curse, oh my god if you take away my people
I'm not gonna kill you. Okay? I'm not gonna kill you. I'm not gonna kill you here find your fuck. Oh
God, no, no, just go
Okay, I
Got it as orgasmic. Is that sounded my god. I got a friend from witch school looking to move to town
Yeah, go for it. More witches the better I think
People are happy. We're grown big. We're going. Oh,
Look at us look at us look at us look at us
Look at us look at us look at us, hen
Might I get a cup of tea for you milady. Yes
Yes, nice in the Hawke's
Indeedy-do nice and hot indeed that mischievous. Monkey has been capped. I shall send them to you for your judgement
Oh, hi. He's defending his cakes. Should we punish him for flinging stuff? Listen monkey? I
Don't make the rules, okay
Yes, I make the rules but I am a slave to the rules just the same as you and in my city
we don't fling poopie if there was what you were flinging a
Monkey is as a monkey is you can't expect a monkey not to throw poop around
This monkey from certain doom you are free monkey
You better not do it again, though
Not do it again, I'm a hero
Goddamn hero some very strange creatures wish to move in the houses. We build should we allow it? Well, I don't want to discriminate
Of course all are welcome in our town
Hey, ho what is this strange place I found myself in outlet. Do you know where we are?
my oh my
Hello, you queenly person there. I do believe I'm a bit lost might I stay in this town for a while
Yeah, yeah. Okay, how nice Albert and I shall find an interstate
I'm sure I'll see you again. Habit seems to like you
Okay
Thank You Albert there's a lot of this stuff in this edition names Mulder, I know Mulder I know
Yes, go investigate the aliens invading our town. Oh
I am sorry about earlier. My circuits were quite fried. I offer my thanks for your help. Thank
You quite logical
All right. Our soldiers are coming home and our assistance in defending our allies has not gone unnoticed
We've been offered a bounty of gold by the captain of their military a good fellow. Okay. Thank you eyepatch. I'm back
I discovered an inferior to cover up large amounts of gold. Do you believe in aliens I do now
Good to know there are other believers out there
Okay citizens from far and wide would you like a fresh cut? Yes, of course you do you look dashing. Let's say I look
Beautiful, but whatever Hey
We've reached 500. Oh
Do I get it a reward do I get a reward?
Woods back up over my head again town people are celebrating
There's a huge festival in the square but a growing population will demand even more happiness. Be sure to keep our approval
Hi, and why just want to give my congratulations? Let's keep working hard. Okay
Nah
That wasn't meant as a question. I hope you're joking madam
I'm never joking. Hey, why'd you have to go and rat on me?
Not pass good mold or won't leave me alone. Now trying to lead a long life here. I don't need all this commotion
Listen, you tried to rat out the skeleton some refugees have arrived in town. Should we welcome them? Yes
More people. Yeah you again. I thought I thought I I thought you were gone. No, no, no
Got out of here. You stupid chest any mysteries afoot. Yeah. Go for it Oh
The festival in Town Square still going strong bringing happiness to all those who attend
It's fine. Whoa. Oh, okay. It's finally done
I'll finish crafting the dragonblade all we need now somebody to wield it
Hardly be here with you and spread the word our heroes if their wish to take up the blade, I'll send them here
Do you cool I've got my night. I guess our granaries stock has been infected
It'll cost us or replace it. But if we don't people could get sick, what should we do?
Save our money. That's what we should do. Now. We'll replace it. Our peoples health is worth the cost
I agree, but I feel like people should have been happier about that one my friend from witch school
Wanted to thank you for your help. So we made you some magical cookies
All right magical cookies you say
There's a party I'd like to go to this evening. Milady might I have the rest of the day off
Yes, go for it. Have fun. Thank you
We will toast to your honor Oh God you this is here to pay it a visit
Should we leave it be now get out of here? You stupid bird
Well, this thing is dangerous
Every time we kiss a chicken. Well the secret dangerous people are happy. The city is growing. Oh
I'm Jarno of the comfy Kingdom you may not believe this but I'm the Royal assistant of kingpin himself
Indeed the very same I've been noodling around this kingdom of yours and I oh wait, what's that over there? Uh,
Wha
Good day. Madam. Did you happen to see a blue fellow come through here just now strains noodly limbs made of yarn. Yes
I knew he was around here somewhere. I'm gonna find that darn yarn
Oh, he's been running around claiming to be the kingpins royal assistant
Which of course he is not. In fact it is I button boy who represents the competing dominio steam Council of crowns
Have you heard of the Council of crowns? Good madam? Oh
No
Really?
Council of crowns this group where the world's top kings and queens gather they discuss matters of
Diplomacy trade warfare and all manner of important subjects surely as Queen yourself you'd be interested in joining this council
I have an idea perhaps you'd be interested in this that Janos been giving me nothing but trouble
If you could somehow put a stop to his shenanigans
I might be able to get a meeting with the PR the advisory of the celestial kingdom
If anybody would be able induct your kingdom into the house who live would be her
What do you say we help you? Catch that darn yarn
Okay
Very good. I'll leave the details up to your discretion. Once Yano is out of the way. I'll set up a meeting with Pia
Thank you for your assistance in this matter of a good madam. I'm sure we will meet again soon now
Okay, Oh God you again? Okay, just
Get it over and O God. Thank you. They're not to be able to get all the way
Okay. All right. Okay. That was pretty good. Okay, my part nice. Kelly told me you have information about an alien life-form
This true, it could change everything. I'd be launching my own independent investigation. I just wanted to come here and say, thank you
Thank you. You get those dirty rotten alien out of here
Well prophets been made in the harbor and by to share some with you. Thank you
We've completed our work on the gardener you please I can't tell but you know, I'm pleased for other reasons
So I'm gonna go ahead and say yeah
I'm so glad I heard you need a champion to wield that dragon blade
Pretty good with swords can take a finger show our friend the dragon a thing or two
No, Oh, what is it you don't trust me
Absolutely not. I absolutely don't trust you reporting in I solved the mystery about who stole mr. Mrs
Bumpkins baking pan want me to turn him in? Yeah. Sure
Crime worth and death it's off to the dungeon for him
Bad crime don't do that. Uh-oh. Have you seen my magical cat pancake?
yes, actually I have yeah, I have actually
Very good. I knew he was around here somewhere
Okay. I thought you were here to darken my doorway. But okay cat trying to tell me something
It seems like he wants help yarn Oh, is he talking about your know? Maybe this cat could help find yarn Oh
Need plenty of tuna, of course, but surely it could be worth the cost
Well, should I hire this cat to find er, no?
I mean if if any animal could I guess it's a cat hope he understands what I want. Oh well nothing to do but wait
Okay, the owners of the tavern are making piles of gold wish to share some with you that's not usually a thing
But okay, I'll take it. The spirits are pleased right now, but perhaps you should grant them an offering of gold
I know the spirit world always appreciates gold and it might prevent them from haunting us in the future
200 gold. Oh
Sure, I guess
Whoa, whoa. Whoa. Whoa whoa, whoa
Whoa. Whoa one of your fishermen has been bothering me. I demand a villager as a sacrifice. Oh
No, no big. No you've angered me now madam. Watch your back
Okay, do you like making new friends I sure do but and if you consider the one I just met
Don't like making new friends. Yeah, it looks like you want somebody to Pat his belly. Okay. All right boots. What about yard?
What about yarn Oh, where's your no? Okay. Goodbye. Some villagers are threatening to leave
Should we pay them a sum of gold should we listen? No screw up get him out of there
No, we're not gonna listen to their demands
Let's do all of them go then it's a dangerous precedent to set we're not gonna do that good to go
Let me stare
Okay, good. Good. Good good
Let me steal from the rich and give - no go away. Where's my knight? Where's my knight? Oh,
Hello. Hello, I am well, I am a scientist I do science for you Queen
You see the city has grown and we have grown to the science community
That is we now have our very own Council science of which I am the leader today
I simply wish to introduce myself
And now I have I have I will visit you again in the future regarding our projects science projects
I think that's two children stacked on top of each other in trench coat. Hello get in queenly person. Oh
how they asked me to come here and tell your story with you a
Yellow bird meets a green bird in the garden to see yellow bird soar higher than the green
Yes
The yellow bird wheels through the sky she shimmers in sunlight. Oh
How lovely?
Oh
I would rather have the green if the green was happiness
High up in the sky the yellow bird meets a blue bird does heal a bird stop to sing with it. Yes
Oh
ho ho
The sweet musical notes of the two new friends filled the air
the singing attracts a flock of nearby birds of all shapes and colors the skies filled with song
Oh what a lovely ending this story. Don't you think I would liked it
I would love to come visit you again sometime queen bee person. It's fun to tell stories with you. Yeah, it's fun
Now your stories have kind of magically affect everything in the real world around us
Hey, fishermen more broth has been made in the harbor. I came by to share some with you. Thank you. Oh
You again
Good god, oh, I don't need happiness that badly
The prison is in need of repairs a few hundred gold
Yeah, okay. Oh my money oh
Oh
It's down below my knees feeling spooky today now
Oh, I some plant people have sprouted in the garden are we allowed to make them official citizens? Oh, okay, that's normal
that's
That's a little bizarre. But okay some families have moved into the new houses. We built should we send them a welcome basket?
Yeah, that seems nice. You're so sweet and thoughtful
God you're thoughtful. Okay? Yeah. Okay. There's twenty happiness. That's good. That's a lot of a penis. That's good
We reached a thousand that's money. That's good
The citizens expect the best from us. Well, I've got the best to give my Bryn's all worn out is my birthday
I don't feel so good. No one. Give me a card. All right, fine. I have a new room
Where's the broom cost $50? What is wrong with you? You swindler I bet it's not even your birthday
hello, hello science of council has devised a blueprint for a gold generating machine take some time to construct this and many resources but
If my calculations are correct, at least it will produce gold steadily for the rest of eternity
Perhaps you might initiate this project with 500 gold. Um
Yeah, okay
Good good. Yes, we'll begin construction right away fires have been breaking out frequently on cabbage street
Shall we install well to make water more accessible there? Yeah
Yep, they love gold already and of gold I'm below a thousand gold for the first time in a long time
They said Oh God. Why do you all want so much gold?
You didn't give me any happiness in return. Oh
Because gold
Jimmy you guys
Owe me a little shit. Yes, let me look
Okay, that's a little gold. That's nice. My lady a man wishes to settle a dispute
He says he is way cool, but his friend says is not do you think he's cool?
Anybody that says they're cool isn't cool
Very well. I shall inform the friend of her correctness
Anyone who goes like I'm cool like me I say I'm cool all the time
I'm not cool the plant people citizens have taken root and grown into a lovely field of flowers. Can you hear them rejoicing?
Aha they are so happy to see the beautiful plants
Okay
Yep bring it on. Oh
Hey again, we're gonna on a video game it's a new thing I came up with think it'll catch on
Probably not. Me, too. I'm excited about the possibilities
Where are your eyes it's a game you play with others and go around killing monsters. You get a sword
I like the sound of that sounds pretty cool. Yes swords are great, right?
So when you slay a monster you get experience points and are you still listening? Yeah, sure. I'm
Good. Well, thanks for listening to my idea. Thanks for the gold for May letting me listen to your idea
Hi grandma, isn't it a lovely day?
Yes, it is. Grandma. Now that you're here very good Deary
My lady might I be the one to take up the dragonblade and slay the dragon
Yeah, go for have fun for the kingdom that dragon will surrender all of its treasures when I am through
Yeah, okay, fine have fun. I guess the people are demanding that a notorious criminal be exiled from the city
His crimes include theft arson and forgery. What do you say shall we exile him?
It sounds pretty bad. Yeah, I'll do it. I'll have the guards do so. Why did that cost me money?
Why that why that cost me money, but why that caused a tiny little town? It's big now. We've got like
Towers and such. Oh, not you
Thank you Oh
Granary, okay. Replace it Oh
Tales of the brave knight of the dragon blade have spread throughout the city. He gives people hope that's nice. That's nice Oh,
Road network needs it's us. It's just money money money. Everything is money money money
You've been drinking quite a little bit of tea madam might I upgrade you to the good stuff
Yeah, yeah first cup is on me though. I'm sure it won't be your last
Why me
No, okay, scientists have constructed a large factory to further their work on gold generating machine pollution becomes a problem for nearby homes
Those scientists, huh?
Bunch of douches. It's my bounty on her. I had almost given up on him. Did you get him? Did you find your new?
Huh
Huh? You got me that cow just wouldn't leave me alone until I came back here was the button boy who sent the cat
He's been trying to steal my position as advisor for years. He claims to be the true adviser, but it's all just a lie
He's only a button after all hi yarn or the blue and the true advisor of the comfy Kingdom accept no substitute. Oops
Gotta run, huh? Oh
Hi Garth seize that yarn well done madam
I'm not sure how much a part of you actually played in this but yarn has been found. I'm in a generous mood
So I'll set up a meeting with adviser Pierre of the celestial kingdom
She's quite busy, but you should expect her to come by sometime soon. Make sure this castle is nicely cleaned. You'll want to impress her
Since to me, all right. Okay Oh
Golda fine. Yes take gold. Can I sacrifice like a hundred people to get two thousand gold again? I'd really like that
That'd be nice
I hope she didn't hear me say that Oh as the city grows weak require more gold to continue expanding our
infrastructure an increase of our construction budget by say
500 will allow us to build a greater number of recreational
facilities
Right. Thank you
On gold ours will be a city rivaled by none at this rate Thank You Man. Thank you. Oh
Fuck off
No, oh
I don't have the gold man. It's getting tougher cuz I just don't have a good way
I still see the other town
Would you like to purchase swords? Yeah, I'd like to purchase swords
Oh dear those youngsters at the council of science and making quite a ruckus with their work
Could you tell them to keep it down? I would certainly appreciate a grandma. Of course
Yes are anything for you? Here's hoping those whipper snappers will listen I
Will talk to them
Well, I told you I don't have your back. Your people will do my snacks, II know
You dare defy me I'll eat you all. Oh
Can we get someone to deal with that guy, that'd be I
Need the gold
so I'm gonna say yes, but it's not cuz I'm
Compromising my morals. I just need the gold
They won't even know what hit him. Thank you
I heard we're expecting an esteemed visitor from celestial kingdom
Shall I go about summoning the servants to prepare the castle for our great guest. Yes, you may of course, of course
It is imperative that she be impressed. There's a petition going around open our borders to the neighboring town. What do you say?
yep via purse peppers
Together our towns grow stronger. Yes, they do. Yes, they do. Oh god, damn it
Yeah, I just give me the goal. Thank you. Go away, please
Hey, could I trouble you for a sandwich? Yeah, okay
Hey, how's it going you and me. We will get along though. We want to tell you a secret
Actually humans because of curse which put on me, I'd stop it if I could but you know
Curses you think you could help me break the curse. I don't want to keep eating people forever
I was going to burn you and frankly for all the people that you've eaten. You probably should be put to death but
Whatever. I'll help you I guess
Thanks, buddy. I knew you'd help me keep an eye out for any magical folks who might be able to break the curse
Okay a whole good day Queen Lee person friend of mine. Albert wishes me to stop I'd say alone
So hello. Thank you for letting us stay in your wonderful city. Well, thank you. Goodbye
I guess there's some food we've been able to store on the grand reasons attract more settlers. Of course. Well people. Oh, yes
I usually looking for someone magical to help the situation regarding a treasure chest
I give you whatever mystic assistance you need for a small price. Of course
Thank you miss hips
Fantastic a curse is it I'm no stranger to those. I'll have your friends sorted out in no time
Okay. Thank you. My god, your hips are incredible. Oh, we're growing again. I didn't know there'd be a third fit. Hello
Greetings. I am Pia advisor the king under Ahmadis of the celestial kingdom
What a beautiful castle you have here. Everything is spotless
I was just wandering through your city and was quite impressed with your citizens
You know the Council of crowns is searching for a fifth member. Is there something you might be interested in? Yeah. Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, I thought as much I'll inform king under amitis
I'm sure he would be happy to meet you and discuss the details there. Thank you
Oh my was that the woman from the celestial kingdom?
This is so exciting the celestial King sits at the head of the Council of crowns
Any connection with them will surely do us well in the future. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy
I mean, I've already got a crown so technically okay. This better not be crap. It's crap. You're crap
You suck go to hell the gold generating machine project continues though
We are running low on supplies more funding modest hundred gold. Yeah
Okay, you bunch of swindlers you bunch of polluting noise-making swindlers. Nope. Hi. Hello, Queen
I am a tree of the Western forests as you can see. However, I have been shall we say shortened?
This is due. Largely. In fact of the actions of your team of wood cutters
My home has been chopped clean through in your reckless pursuit of expansion you have now
Disrupted the lives of myself. Am I good tree folk brothers and sisters
I demand compensation by the way of golden coin so that we might repair this how shall I put it?
Diplomatic rift between us a policy sum of 1000. Oh
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I remember last time I didn't do this and I think it cost me a lot of problemo
so I'm gonna say yes by
Akamai here we go. Oh
The first step on the path to recovery has been taken well this does not go unnoticed be sure that I am not finished I
Oh, yeah
Yeah
I will be speaking with your Basin immediately regarding the matter of a sustainable wood land harvesting
You've done the right thing here today. Michel tree folk will respect that despite your woodcutters aggression with this epital. Good day
May you roots go deep and strong. I
Am poor I am very poor milady. I come across the chest of gold in my advances
Will you please accept this gift? Yea
Thank you. Thank you night. Thank you. Please night more. Hi
he he he hehehe
Hey buddy, hey, I didn't think I'd see you again. Yeah, I think those yeah, thank you. Thank you
ooooooooooh
I'll take it. Good exchange good exchange could trade good trade good trade good trade
Everybody could trade good trade good trade good trade. A
search party is turning up the missing man madam than 9 of his new friends
Ok, can my friends come over the play?
Ok. Yeah, thank you. Yeah
See you Timmy -Oh no not you
Oh no not you not you not you not you
*frustrated moan*
we are making great strides. However, *mumbles* additional funding - a part of
300 gold
I'm POOOOOOOR AGAAAIN
I'M POOR AGAIN
*yells* WHY -why don't I just tax my people?
Oh god not you
Yeah, I- yeah, I'll take it
yeah I'll take the money I'll take the money
yea I'll take the money I'll take the money I'll take the money
*sad mumbling*
Go away! Go awa- I can't afford it. I can't afford it  I can't afford it go away! I can't afford it, I can't afford it
Running out of supplies *mumbles* a modest 100 gold, good god you swindling douches
you swindling bastards!
Queen lady! madam! I've done it! I've slain the dragon! His hoards are ours now!
Wow, I thank you for the opportunity to service my kingdom. It's been an honor
Woah my god, I love that guy. Imma marry that guy
I accidentally stayed up all night eating candy. I hate you
I hate you
loud noises are heard throughout the night from coming from the Council of Science chambers the children have a hard time sleeping Oh,
God not the children. who cares.
I'm gonna leave my kingdom now to pursue my dream of becoming game dev. Goodbye, okay
Goodbye, I guess what the hell is that all about? What did you just give me?
Maybe our paths will cross again one day probably not though
Take this cog to remember me by I've got plenty so you can have this one
Okay, I can hardly believe it Queen but we finally done it construction of the gold general machine has been completed
All that remains is to turn it on
We'll take a couple of days before it becomes operational but we'll begin the process tonight. Won't be long now. No, no
Okay, whatever you say if this consumes all my people Oh God
DO IT AAARGHHHH
Oh
Make way make way for King Andromedus,  Lord of the celestial kingdom!  Hi. Hey, how's it going? Hey
Hey, you don't always need to make such a fuss about my entrances Pia
Anyway, yes. Hello. Good Queen
I've heard much about you and your people we and the council are quite impressed with you and
Would love to induct you there's this one
Small issue all for the existing council members must be presently to adduct a new member
But I'm afraid Queen Chanterelle and Queen Sareth are having a bit of a fight at the moment
We'll need to calm them down and settle their dispute before you can join the council. You should be hearing from their advisers shortly
I'm entrusting you with the task of reconciling these two Queens best of luck to you
HUH, you'll need it
and afterwards that seat on the council shall be yours
Thank you. I'll keep an eye out for the advisers from the Ocean Kingdom and plant Kingdom madam
I'm sure we can settle whatever it is troubling their Queens
What does that make me the earth Kingdom? tiny little town? -dude. Look at the freaking window
Yes, please. Thank you. Okay good
Our work is finally complete the gold general machine has been activated. All we need now to do is to sit back
Enjoy the fruits of our labor many. Thanks to you Queen for supporting us in this project
That better be a lot of gold
It better not be one a day! since we've opened our borders travelers from all over are joining the city
Doesn't it just warm your heart? They sure do it. Sure Do. It Sure do. it's a lovely task so many new friends
That's what everyone considers all the members of their City: friends. The council science has said the most wonderful idea. Yes. Yes
Okay, we've devised an idea to broadcast music across the entire city using a network of sonic hardware
I'm not sure if this would be useful but wouldn't it be fun to try in the name of science?
I'm certain we could do it on a budget as well a mere 100 gold should suffice
that sounds
Terrible that sounds like the worst
idea. Im gonna do it.
Even if you're gonna just start blasting music everywhere in our kingdom
*high pitched voice* UM YEA thats right thats right. We'll get started right away
The streets will be filled with song I think that's a bad idea. I think that's a bad idea, but I did it
Anyway, I don't know. Why wait what the frick? Bonjour I've just finished moving in. You've been here for two months!
What were you doing? Take one person?
What the hell!? what's wrong with you? the gold generating machine spits out a small pouch of coins in the night
twenty. Twenty. t w e n t y
spit out twenty
*sad sigh*
Figured out a mysterious new way to make gold, wanna know how? okay not telling you
Okay. Oh boy, since we opened our borders trade from caravans is increased dramatically be wish to tax the merchants. Yeah, that seems fair
It's fair! It's fair. It's fair. It's faaaaaaiiir
My friend the curse has been lifted. I'm not hungry for humans anymore. This is great. I feel so free
Maybe I can find something better to do with all my money now a charity work or something
It's a whole new Chester from now on buddy. Thank you so much. Well, thank you. But also I liked it
when the Money... those new speakers the builders put in a too loud. I can't hear myself
Think when the music plays I'm going to be circling a petition to have them removed though. Scientists have gone too far
I knew it was bad idea grandma, I just hurt grandma, I'M A FAILURE
NO dont haunt anyone! I'm a failure!
*cries like a baby*
oh god why just curse me
GOD COME ON
What's this I hear about a position to remove the speakers? I say I say its quite upsetting you heard about this
I had no idea people were so upset. What do you think? Do you support the position? Yeah, remove them get him out, err
I suppose is just another failed experiment for the records
you
Stupid idiot and me stupid idiot for trusting you another chapter in the rebuilding of our people's bond has been penned this day
I've spoken with your Mason on the topic of sustainable construction techniques, though
He was not at first wholly receptive to my ideologies in due time. I did convince him to see things my way
Thank you for cooperation such as it has been in this matter.
I Didn't do nothing Hey Oh a very talkative
Tree stump just came by to give me an earful
it was saying something about not cutting down so many trees
I Think. what's the deal? Do I have to listen that thing?
Yes
Really? we're taking orders from trees now? Well, you're the boss
This will slow down our construction some but I can't just say no to you madam. That accents gotten worse
You think of- what the hell?
sir, Tortuga, um
Greetings. Hello. I am sir Toto gov the shell Knights we fight for all that is good and righteous
Is there anything on you might need assistance with you? Madam? Sure. Oh
Very good. We'll set about it at once. We are very helpful Bunch. You'll see~
Thank you, sir, Tortuga. I've been asked by a warrior tribe to the south to supply a great number of weapons
do I have your permission to supply them? I'll need some extra gold to help fill the order
Okay
That seems dangerous, seems like they might attack us with that. Whoa. Whoa, whoa gold
Gold. Alright gold I like gold. good day. I am adviser pontus of the ocean Kingdom
recently a dispute has been raised between our queen and the plant kingdom. a plot of
Marshland has been discovered then must be legally marked as one kingdom's
property since the marsh contains water
Clearly it must belong to the ocean queen. the plant queen refuses to listen, however, insists it should be hers
Will you support our claim to the marsh land? Will you help the ocean Kingdom?
um, Marshland doesn't seem like it belongs to the ocean Kingdom
I mean if you said that you were the lake Kingdom I could understand, no. I won't support  you on this one
Surely you will not believe the marsh should go the plant kingdom instead, huh? Well, we shall see about this. I will be going now
Thank You adviser. it's that slightly magical cat from before does it mean we're friends now, of course
Of course it does! I guess we are. we are.
UH I knew it the warrior tribe to the south
We provided weapons for us taking up arms again
I knew it was gonna happen might I request additional funds so we were able to adequately. Yep. I knew it was gonna happen
I'm sorry, it's come to this. But now we must defend ourselves. I knew it was gonna come to this
I knew ah, it's you again. Huh? You,  those fishermen and at it again! give me a sacrifice or I swear
I'll do something bad. No
What do I you've angered me? Well, I mean you suck. You just plain old suck. Oh hi. Um, hello
My name is advisor agaric.
I represent the plant Queen
Chanterelle. We heard your denouncement of the ocean Kingdom
in this matter of the marshland as a land filled with grasses and plant life that Marsh rightfully belongs to the plant Queen
Therefore we are of course thrilled to have your support
I offer our thanks on behalf of the plant kingdom. good day to you. This makes sense. It makes sense
Oh, I think there's something going on in the sewers
I've been hearing some weird sounds
like you investigate if you want
Okay, Winston's on the caaaaase
Thank You Winston. ghostly figures are seen drifting around the graveyard the spirits appear to have become angry
That's not good Oh madam
The shell Knights have finished polishing every statue in the castle to the maximum level of glorious shine
Are are you pleased? we can continue to clean and maybe make some snacks if you wish? Yeah
That sounds great. Yeah do that. We will not let you down. This castle will be well looked after I swear it. Thank you
That's so nice. Didn't even ask for money. I wish to strengthen the bond between our cities shall we engage in a trade mission?
Okay, why not quite agreeable we shall work together again. I hope spirits are haunting the citizens spread bad luck to the citizens
That's not good. Oh
Hello good Queen
It seems the trouble regarding that marshland has been all cleared up
Once Queen Chanterelle realized she won she was willing to split the marsh with the Ocean Kingdom
Sometimes a leader just needs a bit of respect, you know
Well, either way your input helped break the stalemate for that. I am thankful now as promised your seat on the council
I'll have Pia make the final arrangements inform you when we're ready to induct you. Thank you again for your assistance on this matter
*sings* I'm gonna be inducted onto the council
Oh grandma. It's okay. No, it's okay. Grandma. It's okay. Oh
Grandma its ok, grandma!
Hello I am from the neighboring ocean Kingdom what a lovely castle you have although it is quite dry
Have you ever been to the ocean Kingdom? No, I see not too much of a swimmer, Are you? I can't fault you for that I suppose
Okay. Goodbye. Our city has grown so much that visitors are becoming quite lost. Should we devote more gold the hiring tour guides?
I guess yeah. Okay the tourists will thank you. Oh
You said our citizens were getting lost. So the I as our city continues to expand
I'd like to embark on a project. That's a bit more
ambitious for a daily allowance of a hundred gold my workers can begin the grueling task of
Remodeling our town central plaza. This will surely elevate our city to new heights though
It may take several days to complete. What do you think?
Okay, good good
I'll have the logistics of the project finalized at once and we'll begin work soon
Why do you talk so funny?
420blaze
Oh hi
Day 69 complete hell
Yeah, was we had 420 on 69
might I have some gold to make an offering at the ocean shrine
Okay. Thank you the ocean
Spirits will surely be pleased
Okay, you're weird ocean religion madam. The shell Knights have finished a batch of our famous cookies, please
Partake my Knights will distribute the rest of your courtiers. The city is looking good. The city is looking good
There's got to be like the final level you uh, oh oh
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. do it -Yeeaaah
That's good stuff. The city is looking good
And I bet it's the final one the shell Knights have completed their patrol around the castle gardens picking up litter
I'm pleased to say the gardens are looking
Spotless. Thank you. You're so goddamn. Nice. Oh
There one more day the new high-class housing district looks interesting, but there's lots of cool stuff to
Find there. I think I can borrow the key to the upper district gate
I - uh uhm
Want to say no, but something is making me say yes?
*increasing pitch* I shoudn't address you but I'm tempted to see whats going to happennnn
Yeah, sure go for it. Have at it. Thanks, I'll return this later
It seems like a good idea that I just did
I did a good thing. I did a good thing. I
Did a good thing?
Probably probably where's my gold making machine? Good day madam
We're officially ready to induct you into the Council of crowns. There are a few formalities to observe
Can I skip over those and give you the short version? Oh god, please do oh
Thanks. It really doesn't matter in this way. I won't end up losing my voice. All right gather round everybody
I'm advice to Celeste Queens Queens blah blah blah. You're a queen - you're a good queen. We're inviting you you're accepting
It's all very well and good
On behalf of the castle crowds. I now pronounce you a crowned queen
All right
We're done you're in
Now that you're part of the council represented from other kingdoms may come to help you make sure you do your best to assist them
And sincerely congratulations the Council is the highest rank to which a Queen can rise
God damn central process is complete. Thanks for the patience does never look so beautiful. I must say
oh god, no, that's so sweet, that's so goddamn sweet
All right, I think I'm gonna end this here
I've been playing it for almost two hours now, but goddess I think about this games
It's just so addicting
you just can't stop pressing forward every single time and I have no idea why I never say no to magic and
That's a good one to end on that's pretty good by joining the Council of crowns. You've completed the game. You can continue playing
Yeah
That's so fun. There's something so fun about it like this count this concept
It's not a very like in-depth concept, but I just love it. There's something very addicting about it
You you always want to see how it's gonna turn out
and for those a full game made it is I mean
This is practically a full game. But a bigger expanded game with more options more more randomness. I think it'd be super fun
So thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the other parts of this game that I did in the description below or in the suggested videos over there and let me
know what you think of it and let me know if you played it for yourself and let me know if there's
Cool games like this that you want to see me play. So thanks again. And as always, I will see you, in the next video.  BuBye!,